- Uno dei segreti più diciamo assurdi che ho è che
quando vivevo in un'altra casa, non in questa attuale
avevo l'abitudine di usare i cetrioli delle altre e anche i miei per...trastullarmi ecco. Mi è capitato anche
di rubare dalle altre - Praticamente gli fotteva la spesa - Eh perché ci ciuli il cibo! - Quando hai dei
coinquilini ognuno ha... - Un tot di cetrioli...a mensola
C'era il fruttivendolo che la vedeva "Il
solito? Salve signora" - Ma quindi è uno di
quei casi in cui le dimensioni della verdura contano, che è una grande allegoria
della vita - Ma secondo voi se lo mangiava dopo? (Gianmarco)
- Eh lo sciacquava, quello se lo ripigliava se lo cucinava
- Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova puntata di Vita
Buttata, il tema della puntata di oggi è
"Quello che non ho mai detto"
Un po' di giorni fa vi ho chiesto su Facebook di
farmi sapere quali fossero quelle cose
che vi siete sempre tenuti dentro e che
non avete mai detto a nessuno. Mi avete
mandato dei messaggi vocali e
ho pensato per un tema così importante di
invitare all'interno degli studios de
casa mia una persona che non si sa
tenere un cecio, che è sempre lì come una
sorta di Varys, un signore dei ragni, un
ragno tessitore, sa tutto che non si sa
cosa gli dicono i suoi uccellini, anche
se la maggior parte delle volte non si
sa cosa gli dica il suo uccello, mio
fratello Gabriele - Valar Morgunis - Morgunis
- Ciao a tutti - Madre santissima! - Mamma mia so partito malissimo - "Ciao a tutti"
Io direi di partire a questo punto di partire e ascolatare che cosa c'è
arrivato - Va bene - Allora io ho una repulsione forte per i piedi, però non so per quale
motivo delle volte quando mi annoio
riesco a mangiarmi le unghie dei piedi
e mi vengono i conati di vomito - Non c'arrivo - Infatti
si hai una snodabilità pazzesca...Scusa - Nono ci si arriva ci si arriva - E' vero ci si
potrebbe - Si, ma da lì a mangiare, prova - Come potrebbe
fare, cioè dovrebbe girare le dita...il piede dovrebbe arrivare così - Dovrebbe
porsi in una posizione... -  Come un baciamano, però un baciapiede. Ti ringrazio per questa
confessione. E' comunque uno snack,
organico, a km zero. E' come il sedano
bruci più a mangiare - Però ha detto che c'ha una
repulsione, quindi in realtà è come
quando da piccolo ti mangi le verdure e
non ti vanno - Ma ti fanno bene...Gabriele è
calzante, sia l'esempio che il piede - Valar Morghulis - Io ogni tanto dico Valar Morghulis così capisci...
- Oddio mi sembra i rugbisti di Lavinia - Valar Dohaeris - Senti
perché non fai aria - Ciao Guglielmo, il mio segreto più grande è che mi mangio le caccole del naso
- Vabbè ci puo stare, è una roba gourmet - C'è un regista americano con cui abbiamo
lavorato - Chi è non si può dire? - No. Che si soffiava il naso e poi...come se fossero pancake proprio
- Ma davanti a tutto il set? - Si, è che gli veniva automatico. No e poi "Salve"
E poi ti veniva a dare la mano magari - Ma posso sapere nell'orecchio solo chi è? - Valar Morghulis
Uno dei miei grandi segreti è che sono follemente innamorata di uno dei professori della mia università
e anche lui è follemente innamorato di me e stiamo insieme
- Auguri - Ma? E' sposato? Ma? Ci sono 40 anni di differenza? Niente, non ha detto niente quindi resta così
Auguri. Vi faremo una cesta per Natale. Cioè che gli devi di?
- Ah ti stavi per mangiare le caccole eh?
- Ciao Gu ciao  ospite, penso che una delle bugie più grandi sia quello di dire al mio ragazzo a fine rapporto
che è stato stupendo, ma in realtà non è vero un c***       - Questa è una verità comune penso fra
il 96 per cento delle donne, perché i
maschi dai! - Pensano di essere sempre
stati dei grandi performer. E tu hai questa convinzione?
- Certo! La donna brava è quella che te lo
fa credere bene - E quindi ti lascia in
questa convinzione - Valar Dohaeris...Non c'entrava un c***o. Tu vai a casa felice
racconti agli amici... - E non è vero niente
- Prestazione mediocre. Ragazze mi fate
sapere qua sotto perché lo fate? E'
una questione di imbarazzo, tipo "Almeno
non ti do spiegazioni e non devo... -  No tanto
poi c'è l'altro e quindi poi combinati
tu hai raggiunto una sorta di sufficienza - Oddio il tuo ottimismo mi fa ringraziare Dio che la
finestra è chiusa - Cosa faresti come re Tommen?
"Mpa"
- Ciao Gu e ciao ospite, camuffate la voce se potete, e ciao Enrico che sei onnipresente
Per l'argomento che hai trattato "Scheletri nell'armadio"
ne avrei uno abbastanza pesante da raccontarti - Bello scheletrone
- Vivo all'estero insomma da un po' e tornai a casa per una settimana
In quel periodo ero un pochino dipendente dal mio vibratore, insomma non riuscivo a stare senza
e dopo i primi tre giorni ho praticamente usato lo spazzolino elettrico di mia sorella
Ovviamente non lo sa, c'è da dire che ho usato due sacchetti per alimenti
insomma per schermarlo - Che grande schermatura - E niente buona giornata
- Eheheheheheheh
- Tu che parli tanto mentre loro parlano, vai. Adesso c'è silenzio e non vedo l'ora di sentire la tua voce
- Ma perché state ridendo? - Ho capito ma a me vengono sul momento...Abbiamo come ospite la mia pianta
Gabriele parla tutto il tempo e non mi fa sentire le
cose e poi arriva il momento di parlare
e tu rimani così...Qua c'è scritto fotosintesi clorofilliana
*risate*
- A dieci anni, quinta elementare, finsi di avere un forte mal di pancia per
saltare il compito di matematica in cui non mi sentivo preparata. I miei decisero di portarmi in
ospedale, e una volta arrivati all'ospedale io ero pietrificata, non potevo ormai dire
"Mamma papà sto fingendo" figurati cosa mi avrebbero fatto. Mi diagnosticarono l'appendicite
Beh io ero talmente spaventata che mi feci operare. E quindi adesso ho la cicatrice
dell'appendice ma in realtà non ho mai avuto l'appendicite
- Dimmi te! - Ma i medici non se ne rendono conto che non ha
un'appendice? - Sai che non ne ho idea
soprattutto... -
Mi sa che poi rimuovono semplicemente, ti toccano "qua", lei faceva finta di stare male (Gianmarco)
Ah che fosse un dolore, evidentemente da quella che era la sua
reazione hanno detto "Per forza appendicite" - Questa è
una di quelle cose che è stata
un'escalation che ormai non poteva più
tornare indietro, tipo l'omicidio ormai
Gabriele ma tu oggi stai facendo delle
metafore che non c'entrano niente - Che ne so, per
dire ti casca la cosa "Oddio è svenuto" no ormai è "Ammazza" poi "Nascondi
il corpo" ormai di colpo sei un assassino
- E lo stai sporzionando e lo stai congelando nel freezer per fare il ragù
Ed eri partito magari che ne so che gli avevi dato... - Un cinque - ...Dite sempre la verità
che la verità paga sempre - Bravo sono molto contenti di averti qui
con me. Cos'hai da dire - No ma tanto non si
capirebbe, ve lo confesserei, è una cosa che
capireste solo voi. Gianluigi vieni qui. Ragazzi il "Balletto della contentezza" non
esiste - Io lo sapevo - Allora qualcosa esiste lassù -  Questa cosa tu la metti. Voi non sapete di cosa stiamo
parlando, ora lo spiego - E' inutile! - Abbiamo passato un'infanzia terribile a causa di questo
Io da piccolino mi divertivo a dipingere
fra le varie cose che facevo e Gabriele diceva
che quando io appendevo i miei quadri
insieme a Gianluigi facevamo il
"Balletto della contentezza" ♫ Il balletto della contentezza. Lalalala ♫. Cioè io so la canzone
di una cosa che non è mai esistita
♫ Come è bello fare questa festa...ci sono i
quadri ci sono i quadri ♫
- Io dicevo ai miei cugini che loro attaccavano i
quadri e facevano questo balletto - Uno di
questi si chiama la "Gloria di
Gerusalemme", due case in mezzo alla
terra brulla - Però era bella l'avevo creata bene la
storia - E la cosa bella è che tutti i
nostri cugini, la nostra famiglia, quelli
pure presenti lì, hanno creduto a lui
- No ma a un certo punto pure noi abbiamo
cominciato a crederci. Cioè veramente. DANNATO!
- Scusate ragazzi questo qui è un momento troppo importante
- Ragazzi stiamo girando il video con
Gabriele sulle confessioni e lui ha appena
detto una cosa, hai il coraggio di ripeterla?
- No - Tanto uscirà ormai lo saprete - Ha appena detto
una verità terribile - 22 anni dopo è
uscito allo scoperto - La verità, la
verità!...Sono così contento che vorrei
fare il "Balletto della contentezza"
Tu credevi al Balletto della contentezza? - E certo! (Enrico) - Ed era il mio modo per prenderli in giro della
loro pittura diciamo, in verità volevo
dipingere io. Ero invidioso - Che m***a!
- Geniale!
- Prendete uno spruzzino che lo innaffiamo un pochino Gabriele
- Tutti gli uomini devono morire - Ma che stai dicendo? - valar Morghulis
Ciao Gu ciao ospite,  una volta quando ero ragazzina ho toccato il pacco del mio fidanzatino in chiesa
di nascosto. Brucerò all'inferno - Si!
- Nell'innocenza - Poi era piccola voglio dire, un giochino... - Che vuol dire? - La stavi vedendo come una
cosa sempre maniaca - No c'hai ragione - Invece è molto innocente, magari manco...
Secondo me Gesù non si offeso. Valar Morghulis
- Diciamo che ho giurato di non raccontarlo mai ma per te faccio un'eccezione
La mia coinquilina una sera mi contatta impanicata e mi mi dice
"Ti prego raggiungimi qui" Io vado
preoccupatissima, la scena
raccapricciante che mi trovo davanti è
praticamente, una volta aperta la porta
di casa, il ragazzo con cui usciva, a 90, con una
bottiglia, sai quelle grandi da 66? - Si - Di birra, conficcata nel c**o. E ho passato mezz'ora per
cercare di togliergli quella bottiglia. TRAUMI - Un applauso tutti insieme, perché ragazzi la cosa più
importante è che qui stiamo avendo a che
fare con una ragazza che nonostante
abbia fatto Artù con la Spada nella
Roccia - Temo che non sarà facile tirarla fuori
Non l'ha detto a nessuno a detta sua se non a noi. Ai miei amici glie l'avrei dovuto dire - Come Sansa
praticamente - Si - Quindi si sono messe un piede per chiappa, tutte e due. A parte come fa a
non uscì? - Guarda che un sacco di persone vanno
all'ospedale, in pronto soccorso
- Anche nella vagina puoi rimanere...(Enrico)
- Pensa che a volte alcune persone ci
rimangono incastrate per nove mesi - Dove?
- Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video. Come sempre vi ringrazio
per i messaggi che mi mandate. Ringrazio
anche Gabriele per essersi prestato a
fare questa cosa qui. Fatemi sapere qua
sotto ma non dovete farlo per forza
Che stai facendo tipo nei telegiornali per chi non può
sentire? Fatemi sapere qua sotto, no non me lo fate
sapere quali sono i vostri segreti, l'unica cosa che vi chiedo è se non volete perdere i
prossimi video iscrivervi a questo
canale, attivate la campanella
Noi come sempre ci vediamo la prossima
settimana sempre di giovedì alle 14
Ciao. Sono un coglione! - No, tu sei un coglione!
♫ Il balletto della contentezza, tralalala la la la la la la la
Com'è bello fare questa festa, tralalala la la la la la la ♫